today the nevada state museum of las
vegas officially reopened its doors to
our community
reporter kate houston shares some of the
changes you'll see when it comes to
protocols
and new exhibits after closing its doors
for more than a year the nevada state
museum las vegas is back open for
business
i'm like so excited that it's reopened
this is actually one of my places my
favorite places to go when i lived here
i loved going to the museums many showed
up saturday morning
excited to spend time together as a
family vegas is slowly
starting to open back up again and
that's great reservations are required
masks are mandatory and visitors must
follow the guided arrows to keep
everyone spaced apart
we are very excited but we've been
working on things in the in the museum
changing things around updating some
things as well so we've got
uh new exhibits for people to see when
they when they come here
one of those exhibits is for women's
history month where they're highlighting
six
influential women from nevada such as
lilly fong who was a pioneer
for education others featured include
women's advocate delphine squires
gaming pioneer saren nypretty paiute
activist and author
sarah winamuka and trailblazing channel
8 tv anchor paulie gonzalez
we just saw the exhibit and saw
information about sarah juana mecca like
that's pretty awesome
to be able to see some of the names of
the streets that we've seen here in town
yeah and hear the actual stories behind
the names visitors will end the exhibit
by learning about the women's suffrage
movement
the museum hopes these stories will
motivate the thousands of children they
see
every year as a museum is a really
important part of our storytelling
is really to inspire you know our
children
to get that education and also just just
to learn come here and have fun
in learning kate houston 8 news now
right now the museum is only open on the
weekend from 10 to 4
they do hope to expand those hours as
restrictions continue to ease